علاقات يزيد الامر حين يكون الفارق العمر
الاكبر للصالح النساء والرئيس الفرنسي
مانويل ماكرون الذي تكبره زوجته باربعه
وعشرين عاما من اهم الامثله احد اهم
الدراسات التي اجريت خلال السنوات الماضيه
عن الفجوه العمريه في العلاقات وهذه
الدراسات وجدت ان الازواج الذين يفصل
بينهم عشر سنوات او اكثر اكثر عرضه للطلاق
بنسبه
39% عن زوجين يفصل بينهما عام واحد
العديد من المشاهير اختاروا الزواج بنساء
اكبر سنا منهم دعونا نستعرض بعضهم النجمه
العالميه جنيفر لوبيز تكبر زوجها الحالي
الممثل الامريكي بن افليك بنحو ثلاث سنوات
هي قصه حب نشطه مجددا بعد 19 عاما من
انفصالهما عام 2004 المطربه العالميه
الشاكيرا تكبر طريقها بكيبي عشر سنوات هي
قصه حب امتدت لاحد عشر عاما واثمرت عن
طفلين قبل انتهائها رسميا في يونيو من
العام الماضي بريانكا شوبرا نجمه بوليود
تكبر زوجها الموسيقي الامريكي نيك جولاس
باكثر من عشره اعوام جذب اهتمام العالم
بزفافهما الاسطوري في 2018 عاما الذي
استمر لاربعه ايام
نجمه البوب الامريكيه تزوجت من عارض
الازياء الايراني سام اصغر وا يصغرها
باثني عشر عاما الممثل الاسترالي هيو
جاكمان يصغر زوجته الممثله ديبورا ليفرنس
بنحو 13 عاما وتمتد علاقتهما منذ 27 عاما
دعونا نسال الرجال
والسيدات سالنا الناس هنا في السعوديه هل
يمكن ان تتزوجوا من تكون اكبر منكم عمرا
دعونا نستمع الى الاجابات
[موسيقى]
اكيد واحده اقصر مني المهم ناقصني شيء ان
شاء الله
واحد يكون بنت تنتج اكثر من راجل فلازم
يكون عمره اكبر عشان يداريها في النضج
انا الافضل اننا صراحه العمر يعني ايش
حيكون مجرد
الاتحاد الفرصه هذا والامور تمام ما في
مشكله شوفوا الزواج عادي
وسنه من سنن الحياه وما فيها مشكله
طالما ان هناك
يعني اتفاق في التفكير العلمي الثقافي
على حد ما او بنسبه جدا عاليه
ما نقدر
اكبر مني بسنه سنتين ثلاثه
اذا يعني توفر بنا توافق ويكون في مجال
يعني
متواصل ومباشر بين الطرفين اكيد بتربطنا
علاقه قويه واستمراريه واتفاقيه انه نكون
على وجه الاستعداد لمرحله الزواج
[موسيقى]
من جده تنضم الينا الاستشاريه نفسيه هزان
بن زقر اهلا بك دكتوره معانا في صباح
العربيه زواج الرجل من امراه تكبره سنا هل
هو تفاهم افضل ام انفصال حتمي
اهلا وسهلا شكرا لصضافتكم يا ستي ما نقدر
نقول كده او كده يعني كل حاله لها ظرف
معين عارفه فعندك مثلا نقدر نقول انه اذا
كان الفرق يعني اذا كانت في توافق في
اشياء اخرى فممكن يكون ناجح بينما مو شرط
انه يعني يكون طلاق حتمي ولا كمان مره
اتفاق لانه احيانا يكون في الاتفاق
خلل ليش لانه لما يكون في البدايه يكون
مثلا فانتس ستيج يكون في حب يكون في اشياء
تحسس الانسان ان هو حيكون هذا الزواج ناجح
بس بعد فتره حيبدا يستوعب انه لا لانه
يكون في فروقات لازم طبعا الدراسات
العلميه او يعني بحب انك استشاريه نفسيه
هل من يتزوج من
تكبره في السنين يبحث عن ام له لزوجه بعلم
النفس
بالضبط هو هذا اللي كنت اقصده انه
عندك القاب اللي هي من ثلاثه لخمس سنوات
هذا شيء طبيعي لكن اكثر من عشر سنين يبدا
هنا يكون في
احيانا مع واحيانا ضد طبعا في الغالب
الدراسات والاحصائيات الاخيره بتقول لك
انه نسبه الطلاق بتزيد بعد الفتره الاولى
من الزواج زي لانه يكتشفوا انه هي حيكون
مره في الرقاه طبعا كثير فيها مخاوف انه
ممكن يصل الطرف الثاني حاجه اذا كان
يكبرها مره بالعمر او يكون هي باحثه عن زي
ما بتقولي يعني قنينه الاحتياجات فهي
باحثه عن في ناس عندهم نادي الشيوئيه
بتدور على اب يحتوي احيانا يكون اغلبهم
المنصب المركز المال النفوذ الانسان اللي
مثلا تحس انه تعبانه في حياتي ابغى ارتاح
خلاص فممكن اني اتزوج احد اكبر مني عشان
يامني واحس بهذا الاعتماديه عارفه بس ممكن
بعد فتره تكتشف انه لا ما ناسبها طيب
في مره حالات كثير ما كمل الخطا انه هي
ترتبط باحد اكبر منها لمن تخضع السيطره في
هذه الحاله اذا كانت المراه تكبر الرجل
سنينها طويله هل تخضع للسيطره العمريه
تعتبر نفسها انه هي الاكبر وهي الاحق
باتخاذ القرارات ام هذا يعود للسمات
الشخصيه لكل من الفردين
بالضبط سمعت الشخصيه لانه احيانا بالعكس
هي حاسه انها هي تبقى تعطيه
القياده لانه شاعره مثلا تكون بنقص انها
مثلا اريد هي اكبر فما تشعر بهذا الشعور
لكن حقيقه قد يغلب عليها هذا الشعور عشان
كده بقول لك انه كانه
صراحه يعني احيانا يكون جاي من اشي وجاي
من احتياج عند الشخص حتى برضه الرجل لما
تزوج لوحده تكبر بالعمر برضو يحس انه يبغى
يشعر بالامومه بالاحتواء بالحب بالاحترام
في اشياء كثير هو حاسس ان هو عنده احتياج
فيها بينما لقى ابدا يعني
في كثير يكون مو شرط انه هو عشان هذه
الاشيو تكون في تكافؤ لانه عارفه ايش انجح
هذه العلاقات اللي يكون في فرق في العمر
ينجحها انه يكون في تقارب في الشخصيات في
عندك الانترست الاشياء اللي يحبوها في
كثير يكون عن وعي وعن
وعالي
اشياء مشتركه بينهم طيب
في ناس بتشوف انه لا يعني لما يكون في
عندك ناس اخذوا بعض بعمر كبير معناته في
قرارات مختلفه في تكبير عقل اكثر وبالتالي
نجاح الزواج اكثر من علاقه اثنين بينهم
سنه او سنتين في العمر
بالضبط هذه اللي قاعده اقول لك انه هي في
حالات كمان معينه اللي هي ترى على فكره في
العمر العقلي وفي عمر زمني يعني ممكن يكون
احد عمره مثلا اربعين سنه بس عقله اكبر من
كده فممكن لو ارتبطت بشخص كبير في السن
تلاقيها بالعكس منسجمه مع اكثر لانه
نفس الاشياء اللي يحبوها عارفون مثلا
البلد اللي ابغى اسافرها طريقه التفكير
قريب من بعض الحكمه العقلانيه اكثر عارفه
ممكن واحده تاخد احد اصغر منها لانه هي
تحب الحياه تحب الحريه تحب اشياء تحب اللي
تعرفي سواري بالعاميه للاجري واتنط واعيش
الحياه
فهي حابه احد يكون زيها ما هي حابه احد
يكون يكبرها ويقول لها لا وغلط وصح عرفتي
او مثلا لا ما يصلح نعمل كده او يصلح فهذه
هي اللي بقول لك اللي هي يكون في نجاح في
العلاقه برضو عندك نجاح في العلاقه لما
مثلا انا احد
ما ابغى اخلف ابغى احد يكبرني اريد هو
عنده مثلا خلف قبل كده مطلق فانا ممكن
ارتبط بهذا الانسان فانا ما ححتاج اني
مثلا الاطفال لانه من الاشياء اللي هي
معيقه اللي هي الفرق بينهم لما يكون كده
لما يكون في حدا باطفال احد ما يقدر يخلف
لانه خلاص كبر عارفه ففي عندك
زي ما قلنا زي ما قلت لك اول المقابله انه
في مها وفي ضغط بس غالبا غالبا الدراسات
شويه ضد بس انها بتنجح معها بتنجح معها
طبيعي واحنا بنشكرك كمان جزيل الشكر
الاستشاريه النفسيه هوازن بين ذكر
[موسيقى]
نعم او وافر اني اتزوج واحده اكبر منه في
السن طالما في حكم ايه اللي يمنع ما
اسمحليش كرامتي ان انا اتجوز واحده اكبر
مني لان انا سنه صغير فالجوز واحده اكبر
مني ليه اللي شخصي لا مش محبش كده
لازم احس ان انا مثلا في فرق ما بيني وما
بينها في السن على الاقل خمس ست سنين عشان
مستوى التفكير والحياه والدنيا والكلام ده
كله عادي جدا ممكن في واحده تحبني بحكم ان
انا بتعامل معاها او كجر ليها او كده شافت
مني خلق طيب شافت مني حاجات كويسه في عملي
شافت من الالتزام اهو انضباط فبالتالي
تعجب بيا وانا موافق على الزواج منها ادام
هي انت هتديني الحنان والحب والاحترام فما
فيش مشكله خالص التوافق الفكري ما بين
الطرفين مش هيكون
متناسب يعني وكده
المبادئ اللي انا ممكن احترمها او كده ليه
لا طبعا عادي ايه المشكله
[موسيقى]